cuando vimos por primera vez el concepto
de composición de funciones lo que
hicimos fue evaluar funciones en un
punto o composición de funciones en un
punto lo que quiero que hagamos en este
vídeo es encontrar expresiones definidas
por la composición de funciones por
ejemplo quiero encontrar cuáles
efe de g de x efe de g de x y los invito
a qué pausa en el vídeo para que traten
de resolver esto por ustedes mismos
en este caso gx es la entrada a la
función f x así que siempre que vemos
una x en esta f x es donde vamos a poner
nuestro valor de entrada o en este caso
nuestra función de entrada que es g de x
f deje de x va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de en lugar de x vamos a tener
gdx al cuadrado
gx al cuadrado menos 1 y ahora a que es
igual gx pues gx es esto de acá lo vamos
a sustituir y aquí es raíz cuadrada de
gmx al cuadrado pero gx es x entre 1 + x
todo esto al cuadrado menos 1 así que fg
de x es también una función de x que es
la raíz cuadrada de x entre 1 + x todo
esto al cuadrado menos 1 la raíz
cuadrada de todo esto x entre 1 x todo
al cuadrado menos uno ahora hagámoslo de
otra manera que es g de fx gdf de x y
nuevamente los invito para que causa en
el vídeo y los resuelvan ustedes primero
bueno ahora fx es la entrada de la
función gdx entonces en donde veamos la
x en gx vamos a sustituirlo por fx esto
va a ser igual a
fx entre uno más fx vamos a hacerlo en
el mismo color para que será más claro
visualmente uno más
efe de x uno más fx ya que es igual esto
pasa ahora vamos a sustituir fx fx que
damos que es raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada
- son la raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada
menos 1 entre 1 más
f x que es raíz cuadrada de x al
cuadrado menos 1
esta es la composición efe de gx que
obtenemos esto de acá y aquí abajo es
gbf de x en donde obtenemos esto es muy
claro que estas dos son funciones
completamente diferentes así que
típicamente la composición de una manera
va a ser diferente de la composición de
la otra manera a menos que las funciones
estén diseñadas de una manera muy
especial como para que no importa en qué
orden se haga la composición el
resultado sea el mismo